genome sequencing allows us to actually
identify in pinpoint mutations which can
then help us to understand what brought
about the cancer in the first place
we've sequence several Tasmanian devil
tumour disease genomes now and we
identified a mutation involved in one
gene in the Tasmanian devil cancer known
as platelet-derived growth factor a or
PDGF a for short a number of human
cancers have mutations in the PDGF a
gene or in the PDGF a receptor there are
a number of drugs that have been
developed which specifically inhibit the
PDGF a receptor and these have been
found to be quite effective in some
kinds of human cancers so this leads to
some interesting possibilities of using
this drug in the Tasmanian Devil cancer
so perhaps be an effective treatment in
this cancer too